[موسيقى]
اقدم مستوطنون فجر الخميس على اضرام النار
في مسجد النور بقريه برقه غرب مدينه رام
الله وذلك بعد نحو 24 ساعه على اقدامهم
على احراق مسجد عكاشه في مدينه القدس
المحتله ضمن سلسله هجمات للمستوطنين ضد
المساجد كرده فعل على دعوات تفكيك تجمعات
استيطانيا وينفذ هؤلاء المستوطنين سياسات
انتقاميه تحمل اسم ت في الثمن وقد حذر
شمعون فيراز من ردات فعل الشعوب العربيه
والاسلاميه لا سما في بلدان شهدت ثورات
شعبيه على قيام المستوطنين اليهود بحرق
المساجد في الاراضي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين بعيدا عن الادانات لماذا تتعثر
ردود الفعل فلسطينيا وعربيا على حمله
تدفيع
الثمن وهل تغذي سرعه مراكز القوى داخل
حكومه نتنياهو نيران المستوطنين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وحملاته السلام
عليكم تفيع الثمن هو الاسم الذي اختاره
المستوطنون ومن يقف وراءهم من مراكز قوى
اسرائيليه للرد على اي قرار يمس امن
التجمعات الاستيطانيه لكن من عليه ان يدفع
الثمن في عقيده هؤلاء هم
الفلسطينيون اولا واخيرا
فمقدار في التنقل هدف مشروع كلما اشتد
الجدل بشان مصير المستوطنات العشوائيه او
شرع في تفكيك بعضها س سياسه انتقاميه تبدو
منظمه وهي تزحف من قريه الى اخرى ومن
اعتداء الى
اخر قبل صلاه الفجر كانت النيران تشتعل في
مسجد النور في قريه برقه شرق رام الله
مشهد الدخان كان اول ما استرعى انتباه
الفلسطينيين الذين استيقظوا لاداء الصلاه
احترق السجاد وبعض اثاث المسجد وترك
المستوطنون من خلفهم توقيعهم شعارات تنذر
بحرب وموت وحركوا شجر وقطع زيتون وحركوا
سيارات ولحقوا على مسجد النور هذا اسمه
المسجد الكبير مسجد النور في قريه برك رام
الله وهذا اعتداء اثم بدينا بكل شده بكل
قوه استهداف المساجد بات شغل المستوطنين
الذين لم يجدوا رادعا لهم المسجد هو
الثاني الذي يحرق خلال 24 ساعه بعد احراق
مسجد عكاش التاريخي في مدينه القدس لكن
حصيله تجاوزت الع خلال العامين الاخيرين
ما دام ليس هناك ردع بل هناك عمليه تحفيز
بمناسبه التغطيه والتعم على هؤلاء المص من
قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذه السياسه
ستؤدي الى تفاقم هذا السلوك العدواني
للمستوطنين اعتداءات المستوطنين تصاعدت
حسب احصاءات مؤسسات دوليه بنسبه 50% عن
العام الماضي لتشمل حرق مركبات
الفلسطينيين ورشقها بالحجاره وتقطيع
% من الشكاوى ضد المستوطنين اغلقت دون
توجيه اي اتهام مع ذلك توعدت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
بالرد لا يوجد مكان في مجتمعنا لهذا النوع
من الجرائم اعتداء على مسجد او اي مؤسسه
دينيه سنعمل بحزم بكل وسائل القانون لجلب
منفذي الجريمه للعداله في اسرع وقت تهديد
الحكومه جاء بعد تفاعل الملف داخليا فا
اعتداءات المستوطنين امتدت لتطال الجيش
الاسرائيلي لمجرد ورود انباء عن نيه
الحكومه اخلاء بعض البؤر
الاستيطانيه احراق مسجد برقه جاء اثر
ازاله منشاه في بؤره استيطان وبات يطلق
المستوطنون على حملتهم الانتقاميه اسم دفع
الثمن باستهداف المساجد يشعل المستوطنون
فتنه قد يصعب تلاف عواقبها مستقبلا مع ذلك
ما زالت الحكومه الاسرائيليه تعامل
المستوطنين طفل مدلل توبخه ربما لكنها
ابدا لن تدخل بمواجهه معهم شيرين ابو عقله
الجزيره من قريه برقه شرق رام
الله معنا في هذه الحلقه من رام الله وزير
الاوقاف والشؤون الدينيه في الحكومه
الفلسطينيه محمود الهباش ومعنا من تل ابيب
عيران زنجر الصحفي في الاذاعه الاسرائيليه
اهلا بضيفي قبل ان نبدا مع ضيفين معنا
الان من مدينه برقه جنوب رام الله عبد
القادر عبد الجليل رئيس مجلس برقه وقد كان
شاهد على ما جرى من اعتداءات السيد عبد
الجليل ماذا شاهدت
بالضبط سيدي العزيز اني انا احييك واحيي
صوت الجزيره واحيي صوت الجزيره مره اخرى
اللي هي بتغطي كل الاذاعات الفضائيه في
العالم وحن نستمع لها انا قدمت الساعه
الخامسه فجرا الى المسجد فوجدنا ادرام نار
من قطع المستوطن
المجرمين فهذا العمل مرفوض يعني في دول
العالم حتى الاماكن المقدسه الدينيه حتى
يتوصلوا اللها ويقوموا بحراك ونحن بنستن
هذا العمل جمله وتفصيله ولكن هل هل لاحظت
انه مثلا الجيش الاسرائيلي حضر بسرعه لردع
هؤلاء او
غيرهم لا ولا مره ولا مره يعني بجوز
الساعه يعني حركوا الساعه خسه اجونا
الساعه ت
ولاين سيارات اليش والشرطه على اسس ان ب
يتفرجوا ياخذوا فلام كيف المستوطنين
بينفذوا لاتهم الاجراميه وحركاتهم
الاجراميه فاروا بين الشباب وينهم مواجهات
وهم خرج من الريه
مهزومين بالنسبه للسكان هل هناك استعدادات
خصه لمجابهه
هؤلاء نعم نعم احنا على استعداد في كل
فلسطين في كل فلسطين عامه مستعدين ان
نقابل هذه الهجمه الشرسه بكل ارواحنا بكل
ما نملك شكرا لك سيد عبد القادر عبد
الجليل كنت معنا من مدينه برقه اردنا فقط
ان نبدا هذه الحلقه بهذه الشهاده سيد
محمود الهباش وزير الاوقاف والشؤون
الدينيه في الحكومه
الفلسطينيه بالطبع صدرت ادانات من السلطه
وصدرت ادانات
شعبيه
و مجتمع
عديده ما المطروح بالضبط
الان بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا الادانه
او ايا كان مصدرها فلسطيني او غير فلسطيني
هذا امر طبيعي لكن يفترض الا يكتفى بمجرد
الادانات الموضوع اخطر بكثير من الاكتفاء
بمجرد اذانه لفظيه في وسائل الاعلام من
هنا او من هناك من حيث المبدا الذي يجري
بالضبط هو حرب اس يه محمومه
مجنونه تقودها وترعاها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه نفسها رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هو الذي يغذي هذه النزاعات
العنصريه بالامس عندما يمتنع نتنياهو عن
تسميه هؤلاء الارهابيين بهذا الاسم ويرفض
ان يقول عنهم ارهابيين ويكتفي بان يقول
انهم مشاغبين هذا يغري هؤلاء الارهابيين
لمزيد من العدوان ومزيد من الجرائم بالامس
يمتنع عن تسميتهم ارهابيين اليوم يحرقون
مسجدا لا احد يعرف ماذا غدا يخططون للشعب
الفلسطيني او للمقدسات الفلسطينيه والى
اين يمكن ان يجروا ال الشعبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي في ظل هكذا حكومه تغذي
النزاعات الارهابيه وتغذي النزاعات
العنصريه وتنطلق من منطلقات احتلال توسعيه
لا تؤمن باي شكل من الاشكال بعمليه السلام
ولكن ولكن اسمحلي سيد هباش يعني مثلا
الدكتور صائب عريقات اشار الى ان اعتداءات
المستوطنين عام 2 11 على الاقل زادت بنسبه
40% السلطه الفلسطينيه هل تحركاتها في
مستوى هذا الذي
يحدث دعني اقول لك بكل صراحه نحن كسلطان
ربما تكون تحركاتنا وهذا ليس من باب ال
المبالغه ايه اكثر بكثير من طاقاتنا واكثر
بكثير من امكاناتنا لانه يجب ان ان نعترف
اخي الكريم ان امكاناتنا محدوده و وطاقه
ومساحه تحركنا محدود لكن السؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه بشكل اخر اين عمقنا العربي والاسلامي
المسؤوليه في فلسطين عن المقدسات على وجه
التحديد باعتبار ان المقدسات في فلسطين هي
ارث عربي وارث اسلامي وارث انساني
المسؤوليه لا تقف فقط عند حدود
الفلسطينيين اين هو رد الفعل العربي اين
هو الموقف العربي والاسلامي الذي يغذي
موقف دولي رادع لاسرائيل يمكن ان يحاسب
حكومه الاحتلال على ما تقترفه من جرائم
وعلى ما ترعاه من ارهاب لهؤلاء المستوطنين
نحن نفعل ما علينا وربما اكثر شعبنا لا
يمتلك الكثير ربما ليفعله لكنه يفعل اكثر
من طاقته ويبذل اكثر من حدوده ويحتاج في
نفس الوقت وبكل صراحه الى دعم عربي ودعم
اسلامي ودعم دولي نحن منذ سنوات نطالب
بحمايه دوليه ال عندما يطالب احد الشعوب
عربي او غير عربي بحمايه دوليه تتدخل كل
اساطيل العالم وكل جيوش العالم الشعب
الفلسطيني يذبح يقتل تنتهك حرماته تهدم
مساجده تحرق مساجده تقطع اشجاره و و لا
احد يحرك ساكنا اين الضمير الدولي اين
الضمير العالمي اين الضمير
العربي معنا من من تلابيب سيد عيران زنجر
وهو صحفي في في الاذاعه الاسرائيليه سيد
زنجر في في المجتمع الاسرائيلي هناك ردود
فعل متباينه هناك من اذان ما يحدث هناك من
تقريبا تجاهل وهناك من حاول ان يبرر بشكل
او باخر من اليمين المتطرف لمن الغلبه
الان في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي اولا لا احد يحاول ان
يبرر هذه العمليات من قبل المشغبين
الفوضويين هناك ادانه واضحه هناك استنكار
واضح من الحكوم الحكومه اسرائيليه
والجمهور الاسرائيلي اغلبيه الجمهور في
اسرائيل يستنكر هذه
العمليات خاصه انه بعد في الفتره الاخيره
راينا انه هذول المشاغبين الفوضويين
يحاولون وينجحون بالاعتداء على معسكرات
اسرائيليه يعني اعتداءات من قبل
اي المستوطنين المتطرفين
على الجنود الاسرائيليين ورئيس الوزراء
قبل قبل يوم اي التوصيات الخاصه توصيات
جديده من قبل وزير العدل ووزير الامن
الداخلي توصيات بنسبه
لخطوات الجديده او الاجراءات الجديده ب
حول موضوع الاعتقالات والعمليات ضد هؤلاء
ال الفوضويين مثلا موضوع اصدار فوري
لاوامر كال اداري بحك المشاغبين زياده
فوريه بعدد المبعدين عن المنطقه محاكمه
المشاغبين في محاكم عسكريه ومنح لاحيات
اتكال لجنود جيش الدفاع كل هذه الاجراءات
لها هدف واحد وهو منع هذه العمليات ضد ضد
المجتمع العربي او المجتمع الفلسطيني في
الضفه الغربيه وايضا ضد الجنود
الاسرائيليين الذين يتواجدون في هذه
المنطقه ولكن ولكن اسمح لي سيد زنجر يعني
اسمح لي اسمح لي
فقط اسمح لي يعني رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو قال بانه ستجري معامله
هؤلاء مثل متظاهري بلعين يعني هو في نهايه
المطاف رغم كل الذي جرى يعتبر ان هؤلاء لا
يستحقون معامله اشد من مجرد متظاهرين
سلميين اسبوعيا في بلعين هل هذا تعامل جدي
هذا غ صحيح هذا ليس بالصحيح او تقصد
بالصحيح هذا الكلام قال قاله نتنياهو قاله
نتنياهو هذا الكلام انه ستجري معاملتهم
كمته بالعين
ولكن ولكن هناك الان في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي نقاش حاد بالنسبه لطريقه اطلاح
اي
هؤلاء المشغبين او الفوضويين هل يمكن
تسميه
هدول المشاغبين ارهابيين او مجرمين لانه
اذا لم يتم استخدام اسلحه من قبل هذول
فوضويين هناك مشكله
بتسميه ارهابيين ولكن الحكومه الاسرائيليه
حاسمه وهناك اجراءات صارمه وهناك نيه جديه
لاستخدام كل الوسائل القانونيه المتاحه
لهم وهناك وسائل عديده
يهود براك مثلا يهود براك مثلا وزير
الدفاع نعم يهود براك وزير الدفاع وصفهم
بالمجموعات
الارهابيه بنيامين بن العازر النائب في
الكنيست عن حزب العمل وصفهم بالمجموعات
الارهابيه اذا يفترض انلا يكون الاشكال هو
البحث عن الوصف لانه الحدث واضح
يعني هذا ما اقوله هناك نقاش وهناك خلا
فات داخل المجتمع داخل السياسه
الاسرائيليه داخل الكنيست الاسرائيلي بما
يتعلق بتسميه او او بما يتعلق بوصف هذه
العمليات لا شك انه هذه عمليات ارهابيه
يعني محاوله لارهاب المجتمع او ارهاب
المدنيين في الضفه الغربيه ولكن من ناحيه
القانون الاسرائيلي هل يمكن استخدام ال
كلمه
ارهابيين فيما يتعلق بالاجراءات الخاصه
بهذول المشاغبين ولكن ما يبدو انه هذه
المجموعات الهراب تحول جر ال الصراع
الصراع بين بين اسرائيل وبين الفلسطينيين
الى حرب دينيه نحن
لنا صراع سياسي مع الشعب الفلسطيني لا لا
تكون هناك اي حرب دينيه
والخطر هو الان انه هذه العمليات اي حرق
المساجد وعمليات اخرى ضد المدنيين
الفلسطينيين ستؤدي الى نتائج صعبه
لاسرائيل وهذه النتائج الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لا تريدها نعم
ولكن قد تكون لا تريدها مثل ما تشير ولكن
هناك ايه اشكال داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الان وهذا ما سنتطرق اليه بعد الفاصل
الاشكال يتمثل في الى اي مدى ربما هؤلاء
المستوطنين يجدون ربما بعض التشييع او بعض
الرعايه وان كانت غير مباشره من بعض جهات
في الطبقه السياسيه الاسرائيليه لنا عوده
بعد هذا الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نتناول فيها حمله تدفيع الثمن التي يقودها
مستوطنون اسرائيليون بحرق مساجد والاعتداء
على مقدسات اسلاميه في الضفه الغربيه
والاعتداء ايضا حتى على الجيش الاسرائيلي
اذا نمضي في هذا الجزء الى التعاطي
الاسرائيل الداخلي مع هذه الاعتداءات حيث
اعتبرت تسيبي ليبني وهي احد وجوه المعارضه
الاسرائيليه ان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو يغطي على علاقه حكومته بهذه
الاعتداءات فيما انتقدت صحف اسرائيليه ما
وصفته بتساهل نتنياهو مع اعتداءات
المستوطنين رغم مصادقته على توصيات من
شانها ان تقيد نشاط وتحركات هؤلاء
المستوطنين فقد اكدت صحيفه ارت ان
الصلاحيات التي صادق عليه عليها نتنياهو
موجوده منذ سنوات طويله بايدي سلطات تطبيق
القانون لكن هذه الاخيره لا تستخدمها
واضافت الصحيفه ان الغضب الشعبي
الاسرائيلي جراء اعتداءات المستوطنين على
قوات الجيش دفع نتنياهو الى تنفيذ خطوات
سريعه من جهتها اوردت صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت
مقالا ذكرت فيه ان فرض القوانين يتم بصوره
انتقائيه ففي حين يدافع عن الجيش تنفذ
جرائم ضد العرب وليس هناك من يحميهم وشددت
الصحيفه على ان الفرق بين التزعزع الحاصل
في اعقاب الاعتداء على الجنود قياسا برد
الفعل غير المبالي تقريبا باعتداءات
مشابهه ضد العرب انما يشبه الحال في
المانيا في فتره الحكم
الناسي اذا هذه فكره عن الردود
الاسرائيليه سيد محمود الهباش هل تعتقد
بان هذا النقاش الداخلي الاسرائيلي ربما
يعطي
نتيجه الواضح اخي محمد ان هناك ثلاث دوائر
تغذي هذه النزعه العنصريه وترعاها وتدعمها
الدائره الاولى هي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
التي توفر الغطاء السياسي والدعم السياسي
والمادي للاستيطان من خلال رعايه
الاستيطان ورعايه المستوطنين بكل الاشكال
الممكنه وغير الممكنه الدائره الثانيه
التي تغذي هؤلاء الارهابيين هي الجيش
الاسرائيلي نفسه الذين يتحدثون الان على
انه ربما يتعرض لاعتداءات هذا كلام سخيف
يعني لا لا لا يرقى حتى الى مستوى النقاش
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو الذي يوفر الحمايه
الامنيه لهؤلاء الارهابيين هو الذي يحميهم
هو الذي يمدهم بالسلاح هو الذي يحمي
مستوطناتهم هو الذي يمنع العرب
الفلسطينيين حتى من من من مجرد حقهم في
الدفاع عن انفسهم عندما يتعرضون للاعتداء
اما الدائره الثالثه وهي دائره في غايه
الخطوره فهي دائره التحري ريض الداخلي في
اسرائيل التي يقودها عدد كبير جدا من
الحاخامات الاسرائيليين من رجال الدين
اليهود الذين ينطلقون من منطلقات عنصريه
ويغذيه النزاعات العنصريه عبر التحريض على
العرب والتحريض على المسلمين والتحريض على
الفلسطينيين وتغذيه الروح العنصريه
اليمينيه لدى هؤلاء الارهابيين المتطرفين
في ظل وجود هذه الدوائر
الثلاثه الفاعله في اسرائيل والمؤثره
اعتقد ان كل النقاش ئر في اسرائيل لا لا
يعدو كونه يعني نوع من من ذر الرماد في
العيون ليس اكثر في ظل اصرار الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على حمايتهم وعلى عدم خدش
شعورهم حتى بمجرد الاسم حتى اللفظه ما
بدهم يلفظها واصرار الجيش الاسرائيلي على
حمايتهم وعلى توفير السلاح والدعم
والحمايه للمستوطنات والمستوطنين ووجود
هذا الكم الهائل من التحريض الاسود
التغذيه ال العنصريه ل في الم في مدارس
دينيه وفي بعض وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
وعلى السنه الحقا مات اعتقد اننا يمكن ان
نشهد تفاقما اكثر في مثل هذه النزعه
العنصريه ومردودها على على الشعب
الفلسطيني وسينعكس بشكل او باخر و يعني
ارجو ان اكون واضحا سينعكس بشكل او باخر
على المجتمع الاسرائيلي بالشكل السلبي
الاسرائيليون انفسهم سيدفعون الثمن يوما
ما نتيجه هذا هذه النزعه العنصريه التي
تتغذى على الاحقاد العنصريه والتي تحاول
ان توظف شعارات الدين تاره وشعارات ال
العنصريه ضد العرب تاره اخرى في تبرير هذه
الاعتداءات العنصريه من قبل المستوطنين
نعم على ذكر التحريض الذي اشرت اليه وهنا
اسال ضيفنا عيران جنجر محمد برك وهو نائب
عربي طبعا في في الكنيست عندما تم التطرق
الى هذا الموضوع قال من يتحمل مسؤوليه ما
يحدث ليس فقط هؤلاء المستوطنون وانما ايضا
بعض هؤلاء الذين يجلسون في الكنيسه ولم
يستثني حتى نتنياهو هل تعتقد فعلا بان
صعود اليمين المتطرف اجمالا في في اسرائيل
يجعل هؤلاء يشعرون وكانهم
محميون
شخصيا انا اعتقد انه لا علاقه بين هذه
الحكومه حكومه اليمين الاسرائيليه وبين
العمليات الاخيره ضد الفلسطينيين من قبل
المتطرفين في مناطق ظفر الغربيه اسرائيل
وهذه الحكومه لها اجنده واضحه فيما يتعلق
بعمليه السلام لها اجنده واضحه بما يتعلق
مثلا بالموضوع الاخطر من ناحيه اسرائيل
وهو الموضوع الايراني وهذه الحكومه لا
تريد الان حرب جديده حرب دينيه جديده مع
الشعب الفلسطيني بالاضافه هناك غدب شديد
داخل دوائر معينه في ال
اي قيادات للمستوطنين فيما يتعلق
بالاجراءات المستقبليه لهذه الحكومه هناك
اي اشاعات هناك اي ربما اي تقارير مختلفه
بما يتعلق ب اي قرارات لهذه الحكومه
باخلاء المزيد من المستوطنات في المستقبل
المستوطنون
وخاصه المستوطنون المتطرفون يحاولون ان
يفعلون كل ما
بوصم ولكن ولكن اسمح لي فقط سيد زنجر اسمح
لي فقط يعني هؤلاء لماذا قلت يشعرون بانهم
محميون انا ساعطيك فقط اريد تعليق منك على
ما كتبه اليوم السيد يوعاز اوكون وهو
المحلل الشؤون القانونيه في صحيفه يدعو
تحر النوت يقول ان هؤلاء الاسرائيليين
الذين اعربوا عن صدمتهم تجاه ما يحدث
للفلسطينيين وتجاه ما يحدث للجيش عليهم ان
يعلموا بان هذه المبارات كانت قائمه منذ
سنوات يعني ليست جديده كان يقوم بها الجيش
الاسرائيلي والان اصبحت يقوم بها
مستوطنون هناك امكانيه انه اي
العمليات الاخيره ضد الجنود الاسرائيليون
في الضفه الغربيه وخاصه الاعتداء العنيف
على المعسكر الاسرائيلي للجنود قد يؤدي
الى التحول او قد يؤدي الى
التغيير التفكير في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
فيما يتعلق بالتسلق او
بتصرفات
مستوطنون تجاه المجتمع الفلسطيني في الضفه
انا اعتقد انه نحن الان نرى في الصحافه
الاسرائيليه المزيد من التقارير المزيد من
الصور لهذه المناطق وانا اقول لكم بشكل
واضح الشعب الاسرائيلي الجمهور الاسرائيلي
لا يريد الحرب وخاصه لا يريد الحرب
الدينيه مع الشعب الفلسطيني في اسرائيل
هناك احترام لكل الاديان المسيحيين
والمسلمين واليهود وانا اعتقد وانا يعني
لدي الثقه بانه هذا الواد سيستمر شكرا
الصحفي الاسرائيلي في الاذاعه الاسرائيليه
عيران زنجر شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من رام الله
وزير الاوقاف والشؤون الدينيه في الحكومه
الفلسطينيه محمود الهباش بهذا نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ه